finally new rule since this year's
presidential race features both an
unabashed socialist and a bonafide
capitalist Pig someone needs to explain
to the free market solves everything
crowd that when it comes to socialism
you're soaking in it Marco Rubio says if
you want to live in a socialist country
why not move to a socialist country oh
you mean like Florida where everyone's
on Social Security yes so many Americans
hate the word socialism but love the
concept
Medicare unemployment disability farm
subsidies forget the transgender debate
what America really needs is a separate
bathroom for welfare queens
you know back in February when democracy
was still serious and Trump was still a
joke 66 percent of young people told
pollsters that corporate America quote
embodies everything that is wrong with
America and that more than anything else
is what this election is about and what
side you're on and that debate is all
about your generation older Americans
are more religious and America's real
religion is capitalism and like any
religion it needs a devil and that devil
has always been socialism in 1961 Ronald
Reagan said if we passed Medicare we'd
wind up telling our children what it was
once was like in America when men were
free thanks Nostradamus
oh we hate the red team Republicans
always think if you allow a little
socialism it'll spread out of control
but actually it's the opposite it's
capitalism that we've let spread out of
control
it's it's eight in our democracy it's
eating our middle class it's eating our
health care system our prison system our
news media it's even eaten our food
system so thoroughly that a lot of our
food is no longer something that should
be eaten because because capitalism is a
shark or a tidal wave or pond scum or
whatever metaphor you like to describe
an unthinking force that devours
everything in its path and now the
latest thing it is scarfing down is our
national parks the government just
announced they would be selling naming
rights at the parks like we do at sports
stadiums because the parks are 11
billion dollars in debt and since
capitalism solves everything
cue corporate America who's always
asking one simple question how can we
help nothing in it for us we just want
to lend a hand like when Bill Cosby
offers to help you with your model
so get ready to see the Bison roaming at
Yellowstone with the Nike swoosh shaped
into their annual heels no longer be
having anonymous gay sex in Yosemite 's
rest area number 12 you'll be getting
blown in the Quicken Loans men's room
the Grand Tetons we brought to you by
Hooters and the and the Washington
Monument buy cialis and the Statue of
Liberty buy massingill
give me you're tired you're hungry
you're feeling not so pretty
you know when you're handing over
national parks to corporations when the
price of a life-saving drug goes up five
thousand percent overnight when our
elections are being bought by the evil
puppet from the Saw movies it's time to
realize we're better off if there are a
few things that free market profit ears
can't get their cloven hooves on on the
same day I read about the 11 billion
dollars the parks need there was also
this headline 40 billion dollar Air
Force tanker program delayed because
that's the problem with the Grand Canyon
it doesn't make Boeing rich it just sits
there
stupid Canyon I'm not arguing against
the free market just not for everything
it's funny
older people think socialism is
capitalism's enemy and younger people
think it's capitalism's replacement but
they're both wrong what socialism is is
capitalism's lap-band something to
prevent it from eating everything
you